The Legend of Zelda is a franchise of
games that somehow someway can pull off
any style at once - from forest
adventures to Wild West shootouts to
operating a steam locomotive there's
nothing that these games can't do and
that's especially true when it comes to
being downright creepy the game Twilight
Princess is one of these wildly stylized
titles and is arguably one of the
creepiest Zelda games when it wants to
be mostly for obvious reasons it
features a graphical style that leans
more on the realistic side than other
titles opening the possibility for more
dark gruesome scenery and atmosphere but
one creepy scene in particular stands
out more than the undead within the
arbiters grounds more than the demonic
possession of snow-peak ruins more than
the childish screams of a power-hungry
madman if you've played the game you
know what I'm talking about and if you
haven't consider yourself warned about
spoilers there's this one cutscene that
plays right before Lincoln Midna set out
to enter the Third Temple the water
temple you see in the game before the
three initial temples which each reward
Lincoln Midna with a piece of the
ominous fused shadow artifact there are
light spirits that must be awoken these
light spirits often give the duo advice
on their journey and are even
responsible for informing link that he
is the reincarnation of the hero
fast-forward past the light spirits fair
on and Elden and we come to lanayru--
guardian of linear province in which
lake hylia and by extension the water
temple itself resigned after lanayru--
is awoken the spirit proceeds to give
its advice to link but this time it does
so by way of a vision now this vision is
what I'll be breaking down and talking
about so because I'm going to be cutting
up video quite a bit while discussing
what's happening I'm going to play it in
its entirety right now so that you have
it fresh in your mind take a look at
what the light spirit linear ooo has to
say to link
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
after watching the cutscene and being
thoroughly creeped out there are a
couple things that are obvious about the
scene in the first place it's obvious
that Lynnae rue is showing length of
vision as a warning the powers that
Midna is asking link to uncover are the
very same powers that the light spirits
themselves sealed away because the fused
shadow is an immensely powerful relic
that the goddesses themselves came to
fear secondly it's relatively obvious
that the vision uses link and Illya as
placeholders to represent other hylians
rather than representing well Lincoln
Aelia themselves but there are more
questions raised about the actions
perceived in the vision than there are
answers
why did Illya try to kill link why did
link kill Illya why does link change
clothes why does he have no eyes here
and here but he does here why is there
Dark Link No why are there three dark
links why does blink eye X Dark Link
scream at the end and why does Illya
duplicate herself and they all
collectively jump off a high dive in
slow motion while laughing
uncontrollably let's jump right in shall
we breaking it down piece by piece first
off were shown link flying amidst
nothingness he doesn't look like he's
having a bad time but rather just like
he's curious the texts were given is a
shout out to the creation story from
ocarina of time which is a more detailed
version of the three golden goddesses
creating the world we know in-game note
the same music being used
[Music]
it is important to note that when it
mentions on screen that quote always
chaos end quote
this isn't meant to imply any sort of
negative atmosphere this simply reflects
what is a round link nothing empty black
nothingness while it is true that the
word chaos does imply an insurmountable
plethora of activity or motion when
speaking of creation and existence in
concepts of infinity the term could be
used to describe both everything and
nothing link watches the light show as
the goddesses whiz by creating the world
in front of him granting power equally
to all who dwelt in the light in other
words all men are created equal link is
represented here simply as himself being
aware of the creation taking place
around him a key concept to remember for
this entire vision is that link is
really linked when you see blue in his
eyes
Lincoln Illya are both shown watching
the end of creation as they look at each
other with a nonverbal remark on the
wonders they just witnessed at the hands
of the goddesses the Sacred Realm is
described as the lands where the goddess
is descended in zelda lore the Sacred
Realm is a metaphysical plane of
existence parallel to our own we then
see what appears to be the goddesses
colliding and creating the familiar
Triforce if we contrast this with the
creation scene from Ocarina of Time we
get the additional detail that the
Triforce was created at the goddesses
point of exit from our world the next
information were given is that the
creation lived in peace until word of
the Sacred Realm spread throughout
Hyrule this wouldn't be a problem at the
Sacred Realm didn't house the Triforce
which has been the pivotal relic
responsible for the entire Legend of
Zelda series due to its promise of
granting the users wish were then shown
Ilia holding a knife immediately after
which we see her eyes have gone blink
signifying this is no longer Ilia we're
looking at this is representative of
even the most innocent of citizens in
Hyrule coveting the omnipotent power of
the Triforce and turning on one another
in bloodthirsty battle the battle that
the vision refers to doesn't have a
confirmed timeline placement but we can
most likely assume that a
as the infamous hyrulean civil war which
fun fact was the same war that was
responsible for sending the hero of
times mother into the Lost Woods to give
her son also known as the hero of time
into the care of the great Deku Tree and
thus spawned the events of Ocarina of
Time link or rather the individuals link
represents defeat sylia and proceeds to
run towards his goal the triforce the
cut to the next scene shows link running
but now he's clothed in his heroic garb
for some reason this may seem like a
small adjustment but it's actually
hugely impactful as it signifies the
transition from a storytelling
perspective to a very neat half
storytelling half warning section of the
vision and here's how that makes sense
link is running towards the Triforce
right think again he's actually running
towards the fused shadow which is
actually what he's doing in game at the
time trying to regain the pieces of the
fused shadow for Midna the fact that you
can see his blue eyes and the signature
green tunic and the fused shadow
overlapping the Triforce signifies this
on the other hand the story is still
being told historically of how unwanted
intruders known as the interlopers and
being played by three dark links
appeared from among those that dwelt in
the light they wielded powerful magic
and are shown to grant themselves access
to the Sacred Realm
the fact that they are dark links is a
powerful message in and of itself
because Dark Link represents the
darkness inside link himself Dark Link
is a picture of the evil potential
inside every living being
which ties into the message of this
vision it switches back to a warning
message when they're shown vaporizing
link and duplicating his exact
appearance on one of them this is a
clear message for link directly
foreshadowing what the falling Ilias
tell link later on about those who do
not know or who do not fearfully respect
the power of the fused shadow being
ruled by it the darkness inside him the
dark link becomes him but as you can see
his eyes are blank meaning this is the
dark potential inside link that has now
taken over and there is none of the hero
left inside now switching back to
storage
we then see that the fused shadow was
powerful enough to grasp the attention
of the golden goddesses themselves who
ordered three of the light spirits to
intervene and seal the fused shadow away
within the forest fire and water temples
the interlopers are caught off guard by
this as their pride blinded them to the
fact that the golden goddesses and their
creations of light were still far more
powerful than the interlopers were the
last we see of the interlopers is the
one that looks like link screaming in
horror and then just vanishing
presumably killed by the light spirits
and nothing more said of them this again
carries a double message and story but
also warning if link does allow the
darkness inside him to take over and be
ruled by the fused shadow he will be met
with a swift and merciless defeat by the
hand of the light after Linnea reveals
to link that the power shown to corrupt
man is none other than the fused shadow
we are given one last vision the
infamous part that everybody knows of
that shows Illya
a bunch of Ilias giving link a final
resounding warning then laughing while
descending upside down inexplicably this
is where the vision meets its darkest
segment the background is back to being
completely black completely void
completely nothing alike to the
beginning of the vision before creation
this means the a leas we see are no
longer in creation they're outside of it
but still descending this is
representative of the afterlife and
descending into death what we're looking
at is a bunch of ileus maniacally
laughing while plunging to their eternal
slumber and it makes link smile he's
experiencing the first glimpse of the
fused shadows power beginning to take
over he's hallucinating about all those
who would no longer stand in his way all
those as weak as Ilia he could easily
kill and rule forever
fortunately link snaps out of it before
it's too late and spoiler for the rest
of the game I suppose he doesn't get
possessed but needless to say linear
pulled no punches when giving link this
vision of warning link could now proceed
forward knowing full well the
during pull of power the fused shadow
commands and that he is not immune to
its evil wiles though it meant well in
the end the scene still lives a skin
crawling memory for those who have
played through Twilight Princess and for
those who have now watched this video
okay thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this creepy explanation
video please leave me a like as it'll
help get this video spread around on
YouTube and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more juicy Zelda
content to come comment below letting me
know what you thought of this breakdown
and if you want to see more content like
this in the future spook Tober isn't
over yet folks so expect even more of
the creepy caliber in the next few weeks
as always huge thank you to all of my
patreon supporters including the new
editions sexy calzone and alex Evette
you guys are all so amazing and make my
day everyday if you're interested in
getting your name on this list and other
benefits check out the link to my
patreon page in the description below
also in the description is the link to
my discord server which grows by the day
join us as we discuss all sorts of
amazing Zelda topics and be in the know
for all my latest updates on masks
antenna bandit I think that's about all
I've got for you this time so without
further ado this is mnb signing out have
a great rest of your spooky day peace
[Music]
[Music]